time for real talk everybody and Glenn
if Balto is giving us something to talk
about she's many things an Oscar winner
a mom a self-proclaimed wellness guru oh
girl just pulled a Romy and Michele
moment and pretty much sort of claimed
that she invented yoga yes the very
ancient practice in an interview with
The Wall Street Journal magazine when it
says quote I remember when I started
doing yoga and people were like what is
yoga she's a witch she's a freak
Oh luckily apparently Gwyneth was there
to explain it to the world she says
quote forgive me if this comes out wrong
well it kind of did Gwyneth but I went
to do a yoga class in LA recently and
the 22 year old girl behind the counter
was like have you ever done yoga before
and literally I turned to my friend and
I was like you have this job because
I've done yoga before Wow Gweneth oh wow
yeah weird flex and not okay gotta say
this is a big question mark for me
Gweneth first of all you don't need to
call a 22 year old a girl she's a woman
and second of all I mean I'm not sure
that Gwyneth was taking was taking on
inventing yoga but she was definitely
taking credit for bringing yoga to the
masses we went back in history and
thanks to yoga basics we got educated
real talk the beginning of yoga
originated in ancient India over 5,000
years ago long before as good as you
look for your age when Athlon before you
report yoga gurus from India later
introduced yoga to the West and real
talk back in the 80s yoga was already a
fairly popular form of physical exercise
across the Western world and gwennyth
was born just in 1972 so
Gweneth not sure that as an
eight-year-old you brought us yoga in
the 80s that's a lot of downward dog
[Music]